have you had to deal with anything
outside of that body-shaming wise with
this getting oh did I look like a man
that I went on steroids
people say whatever they want I don't
care you look damn good I'm doing what I
can do
full body transformation work in
progress you're still considered a work
in progress
yes see I gotta get like I'm gonna take
menopause head on and kick its ass I
truly believe that working out eating
well is in taking your supplements is
really the key to like staying young I'm
48 years old I started to see just a
layer of fat developing around my
midsection and I'm like oh hell no this
is not happening I wish I could teach
everybody that's one of your menopause
like it trust me you don't have to
accept it you can reverse it
walk sexy boom boom boom boom I won my
first fitness competition which I didn't
expect to win at all
now I've qualified to go to the next
level I'm excited and scared at the same
time so we're gonna ramp it up yeah my
workout has been consistent I haven't
stopped the workout I'm like I get up
4:30 5 o'clock in the morning and eat a
little bit then I go work out for about
two hours and then I do an hour of
cardio every day five six days a week
squeeze those glutes on the way up
squeeze them under where are three new
things you've learned about Fitness
health wellness but you can pass on to
people one is it doesn't matter what age
you are you can do it I would say 80% of
it is your diet and for women like
lifting heavy weights everybody thinks
like oh I'm gonna get bulky I'm gonna
get this no when you build muscle and
you eat that extra protein your body is
burning fat all day long so girls eat
your protein all day long it's really
your diet like you have to be really
strict women think like well I'm just
not gonna eat and I'm gonna be thin well
you're anything that you're in have zero
muscle
time zero and you're gonna have your
body fest can be higher than we think it
is so when I started I mean I thought my
diet was great I lost like sixteen
percent body fat right you're down to
fourteen percent body fat which is crazy
right so it it just works like it
managed to be lazy you're building
muscle as fast as your body fat so it'll
be like your scale will not move but
you'll notice your compositions changing
don't step on the scale that's all I can
say